63e axes des gilets jaunes les
manifestants effectueront leur parcours
de faidherbe chaligny à partir de 13
heures en passant par jaurès avant
d'aboutir un vivier sur un parcours a de
plus de 8 kilomètres à d'autres appels à
la manifestation en région parisienne
ont été lancés à montreuil et pantin
notamment à londres
les gilets jaunes français entre autres
manifesteront en faveur d'assange devant
la prison à de belles marches et pour en
parler nous sommes avec priscilla lidove
ski gilet jaune
bonjour bonjour merci d'être avec nous
sur ce plateau alors l'actualité sociale
depuis le mois dernier et dominé par les
retraites comment les illusions de
trouve-t-il leur place parmi cette
mobilisation et cette cette réforme des
retraites
les légions je pense que depuis le début
du mouvement en tout cas moi je l'aimé
très tôt que les retraités étaient bien
présents voilà dès le mois de novembre
pas mal de personnes se défendre est
déjà par rapport à un nouveau précaire
des retraités
que ce soit au sein du mouvement des
jeunes ou en dehors
et en fait aujourd'hui le fait que cette
réforme viennent fragiliser davantage le
statut des retraités et des futurs
retraités fait que voilà moi j'ai aucun
étonnement de voir les jets les jeunes
en dehors parce qu'ils sont aussi
concernés et puis ce qui est défendu par
les jeunes en général ce sont les
inégalités et le pouvoir d'achat qui est
en baisse continuellement et puis
d'autres sujets qui ont été revendiqués
sur la plateforme dur et des bas mais le
fait que les jeunes manifestent au sein
des des cortèges pour défendre le fait
que qu'il fallait retirer cette réforme
pour moi est absolument normal alors à
propos des retraites on l'a appris hier
soir l'avis défavorable du conseil
d'état sur la réforme du gouvernement
cette institution la plus haute de
l'administration critique sévèrement les
projections financières et les
engagements pris par l exécutif
hélas le pouvoir de révoquer le projet
loi est ce que c'est une bonne nouvelle
pour tous les opposants à cette réforme
et je pense que toute nouvelle qui va
dans le sens du retrait même si c'est
pas un retrait
mais c'est juste un pas en arrière et
est une bonne nouvelle puisque les gens
manifestent depuis un certain nombre de
temps il ya beaucoup il ya beaucoup de
grèves que ce soit dans le cadre de vous
avez de manifestation faites par les
syndicats tout soit des gilets jaunes
qui organise des mots des manifestations
pour rejoindre les cortèges de des
syndicats les groupements intersyndicaux
moi je pense que de toute façon à mon
bout d'un moment quand on est maintenant
la rue justement qu on manifeste on est
censé avoir des réponses en face des
réponses politiques et les mouvements
des jeunes est énorme pour en témoigner
puisque ça fait un an que les
manifestations qui a pas de réponse
politique donc normalement c'est la
démarche quand on fait des
manifestations et des actions
désobéissance civile d'avoir des
réponses politiques en phase donc
peut-être que c'est le début de quelque
chose mais c'est toujours pas ce qui est
demandé en définitive alors hier le dip
aux deux dispositifs de sécurité étaient
assez impressionnants ont mis en place
par didier lallement le préfet de police
avec d'autres gilet jaune vous alerter
de plus en plus le public à propos des
problèmes auxquels vous faites face les
violences policières notamment et aussi
les censures sur les réseaux sociaux
oui en ce qui concerne les violences
policières justement on a travaillé avec
l'observatoire parisien des libertés
publiques qui a produit un rapport qui
explique ce qui s'était passé lors de la
date anniversaire du mouvement né chez
les jeunes donc le 16 novembre dernier
en expliquant ce qui se passe déjà
l'heure des manifestations c'est à dire
que voilà les usage de la force et
disproportionnée les observateurs qui
étaient sur place ont pu faire état de
tout ce qui c'était passé sur cette
journée là mais ils sont déjà présents
lors des autres manifestations aussi et
on peut on peut voir que voilà il avait
aucune volonté de laisser le cortège
démarre et à cette date là que tout a
été mis en place pour que les gens
restent sur la place que l'interdiction
ya pas eu d'interdiction légalement
produites parce qu'on est censé avoir eu
notification et le préfet l'allemand qui
avait fait un discours en disant qu'il
annulait la manifestation n'a pas le
droit de le faire sur les organisateurs
qui peuvent aller une manifestation est
pas un préfet il peut interdit une
manifestation projetée est pas une
manifestation qui a déjà commencé donc
en fait ce sont toutes toutes ces
manifestations en fait qu'ils sont le
maintien de l'ordre lors de ces
manifestations n'est pas adéquat
les personnes qui sont mises en place
les officiers se sont ne sont pas
forcément formés au maintien de leurs de
la bac la brave se sont pas des aidé les
officiers formés pour le maintien de
l'ordre manifestation est en fait la ldh
et les observateurs font déjà des
rapports là-dessus et c'est absolument
pas normal
à côté de ça lorsqu'on essaie de vous
voyez les vidéos qui sont produites lors
des manifestations lorsqu'elle témoins
de violences policières
elles peuvent servir de preuve lors des
enquêtes qui sont derrière qui sont
faites par l'igpn sauf que l'igpn classe
sans suite systématiquement tout ce qui
est fait donc c'est une aide
supplémentaire d'avoir ces vidéos mais
on constate que c'est pas suffisant
et quand on voit qu'on est davantage
censuré sur facebook on peut se poser
des question peut se poser la question
de l'indépendance de facebook ou si
c'est pour ça que hier on a été à
quelques-uns demander des comptes à
facebook en demandant des rendez-vous
responsable parce que c'est absolument
talent même que depuis un an soit
censuré en soit bloqué sans autre
information plus dire filmé une
manifestation ce n'est pas illégal donc
pourquoi facebook blocs systématiquement
les gros comptes qui publie des vidéos d
les appels à manifester c'est une vraie
question quant aux à facebook
aujourd'hui au niveau là l'idée liberté
c'est assez ingrat un vrai
questionnement sur independence day et
sur cette fameuse censure justement sur
ces sentir concrètement aujourd'hui
comment vous voyez l'avenir de gilet
jaune
alors personnellement je continue à
manifester sur certaines grosses dates
et avec un certain groupe de gilet jaune
on a monté une fédération
voilà une fédération d'associations qui
essaie de se battre localement noria des
antennes associatif qui sont montés et
puis elles sont appelées à le faire sur
le site internet de la ligue citoyenne
pour que justement on soit un réseau un
peu plus fort et plus organisée c'est
pas c'est une émanation du mouvement des
jeunes mais c'est pas le mouvement des
gilet jaune c'est vraiment une
fédération qui tend à vouloir se faire
entendre davantage et a failli et a
forcé en face à ce qui est une réponse
puisqu'on nous dit voilà vous n'existez
pas on sait pas qui vous êtes on sait
pas ce que vous revendiquez après plus
d'un an
donc c'est bien dommage mais on est on
est obligé de s'organiser comme ça pour
ce qui concerne les mouvements des
gilets jaunes on sait les revendications
sont très claires elles sont dans la
plateforme du vrai des barrières
manifeste qui a été fait qui recense
toutes ses bas ses revendications et les
deux laboratoires d'étude universitaire
qui ont analysé synthétiser ces
résultats ont fait un gros travail et
c'est pas du tout pris en compte
donc le gouvernement c'est absolument où
trouvez vous trouvez toutes ces
revendications là mais la question c'est
est-ce qui a la volonté de le faire
parce qu'avec encore quelques-uns on a
fait un courrier pour durrrr président
veut vous remettre se manifestent ils
n'ont pas répondu
donc voilà je pense qu'il ya une volonté
de ne pas de ne pas prendre en compte
est un déni de ce qui est en train de se
passer en france de toute façon
accélérée entendons par le gouvernement
mais une façon plus générale assez ça
d'un point de vue plus global
l'actualité internationale est aussi
riche en soulèvement populaire que ce
soit à hong kong
colombie au liban même en algérie qu'est
ce que ça vous inspire
moi ce que ça m'inspire c'est que de
plus en plus on se rend compte que ce
sont toujours les mêmes qui sont
privilégiés toujours les mêmes qui sont
responsables de la condition des petits
malins de la société que ce soit au
niveau des activistes du climat partout
dans le monde qui se mobilisent pour
dénoncer un certain nombre de choses et
on constate que les cibles entre
guillemets des actions de désobéissance
civile sont les mêmes quand on dénonce
les gros pollueurs quand on dénonce ceux
qui ont des avantages fiscaux un de ceux
qui licencient alors qu'il reçoit des
avantages et qui devrait embaucher on
constate que ce sont les mêmes on a les
mêmes responsables en face de tout ce
qu'ont suivi et je pense que c'est c'est
vrai partout dans le monde à avoir des
échelles plus ou moins importantes
mais c'est vrai partout dans le monde et
là elle et je pense que l'échelle
internationale les gens en ont marre et
disait stop ça suffit ou de puisards
depuis un certain nombre d'années c'est
nous qui payons les prairies c'est nous
qui faisons les frais de vos mauvaises
décisions prises depuis un certain
nombre d'années
la jeunesse se mobilise de plus en plus
moi je me souviens pas avoir une vie une
telle mobilisation des personnes qui ont
14 15 16 ans aujourd'hui ça se voit de
plus en plus et je pense que c'est un
message fort qui est envoyé aux
différents gouvernements
il est temps qu'ils prennent leurs
responsabilités et qu'ils pensent que
kiss kill se souvient qu'il travaillait
pour la société et pas l'un et ses pales
inverse
merci beaucoup puisqu'il allait de ski
dernière a répondu à nos questions en
direct sur rt france